this is a new exciting online video  contest so we've got $30,000 in prizes  [Music]  what's hated by unions as businesses  weary and dropping coverage like the  skin secondary causing thousands of  layoffs taking install what's so good  for people that they're forced to enroll  what's a law that's so good folks who  passed and defended it see it and got  waivers to be exempted it's like olestra  at first it sounded hit but we quickly  found ourselves dealing with a whole lot  of show Bhama care  unions and businesses both in despair so  to recap young people your hours get cut  and your income goes down and your  premiums up and the taxes you pay with  the cash you have left go to pay for a  stupid video contest having Obama  Obamacare  unions and businesses both in despair  by doctors and unions are mad not since  Billy Ray Cyrus has someone made  something this bad